[Musique]
alors nous sommes à l'espace richeau
magnifique espace réchaud à Versailles
avec un artiste exceptionnel
extraordinaire merci Gérard tissovan
bonjour bonjour je suis ravi de vous
rencontrer d'abord je suis pas le seul
parce que je viens dans cet espace
richaut il y a déjà aujourd'hui 1500
personnes qui sont venues voir votre
exposition d'origami alors il faut dire
faut raconter ce que c'est d'abord
l'origamie
c'est au début c'est un art de prière
comme si ça payer une feuille de papier
sans mes coupables et
depuis à l'époque
de générations
très souvent mais quelquefois les il
faut avoir comment dire
[Musique]
minuscule ou je fais des pièces
gigantesque alors c'est ce qui est
amusant aussi c'est que vous dites
minuscule je vais faire un éléphant il y
a déjà de l'humour et puis vous je crois
qu'on peut la voir il y a une pièce
gigantesque qui fait combien
au départ c'est le 25 mètres de côté et
je travaille plus de d'une semaine donc
une fois archevé le lion qui fait 8
mètres 50 de long 4 mètres 50
kg 130 kg
de côté je travaille deux semaines de
suite
aller et retour ça fait des kilomètres
le prix par jour
le lion 2 cm l'éléphant est-ce que c'est
une question un peu bête parce que
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose qui vous
disiez c'est un défi de faire tout petit
est-ce que c'est plus difficile de faire
2 cm que de faire 8 mètres
légèrement différent l'éléphant que vous
avez mis sur le millimètre c'est moins
de détails que les grands on ne voit pas
les défendre donc j'essaye de réduire
la difficulté de mes prix pour enfants
obtenir un combat de boîte tout de suite
que c'est un éléphant mais je peux faire
des chevaux je perds aussi les bateaux
je fais presque tout mais en miniature
comme l'arche de Noé
à l'intérieur c'est incroyable
si vous avez mis remarqué il y a des
pièces
juste un mot quand même alors ici ce
sont des animaux
vous aimez beaucoup j'aime beaucoup
parce que c'est le monde entier c'est ça
comment on dirait c'est
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment beau de
voir une pièce comme un oiseau
je ne sais pas qui a créé pourquoi le
bec jaune
les yeux bleus les plumes
flamboyants et chaque
l'endroit ça empire pourquoi c'est
l'endroit doit être rouge pourquoi en
séparant de la surface simplement
quelques minutes
ou vert c'est incroyable
la création alors ça c'est du 9 par
exemple qu'on voit que c'est dans la
maison Vito
les différences de couleurs alors c'est
c'est pas après après
la parcours un peu les
mallettes les bagages et il y a des
couleurs bleu rouge de 8 ans jaune
à tous les marques de goulot verte
d'accord
des pièces pour envoyer expieriez au fur
et à mesure vous créez chez vous donc
votre atelier vous créez parfois sur le
lieu vous l'avez créé sur place parce
que là
les autres pièces vous avez un atelier
chez vous malheureusement nous avons une
petite maison oui mais je peux au fur et
à mesure sur place chez moi quelquefois
je prends un terrain de basket-ball dans
la ville que comme son serpent et le
jour où
il n'y a pas de terrain
j'essaye de créer des tests plus grands
parce que et une fois payé quelques plis
de base le papier ça réduit très vite
pris et je peux rentrer chez moi pour
mettre sur pied d'accord mettre en
mouvement et j'aime beaucoup chaque
pièce de plus minutieusement et je donne
aussi le volume l'expression et le
mouvement que j'ai vu répéter sur la
c'est du papier plié et pourtant il y a
de l'expression
c'est absolument formidable alors on va
parler un petit peu de votre parcours si
vous êtes vous êtes né au Cambodge
mais après la naissance que j'ai refusé
évidemment mais je me souviens quand
j'étais tout petit dans mon pays natal
je n'ai pas la chance de jouer comme
tous les garçons en France il faut créer
soi-même il faut jouir et grâce à ma
Gomez
initié quelques prix de base comme les
cartes tous les gars en France il est
beau Mao les avions avancer etc mais à
partir de ces bases là
des milliers des milliers de façons de
prier dans un feuille maintenant la vie
il y a toujours la base
comme
la musique
ou la peinture la peinture comme vous
avez vu un tableau c'est quoi
représenter quoi en réalité il y a un
trait absolument
confort un tableau super et des milliers
et des milliers les gens qui tendent
comme vous mais aucune somme là
possible de composer et le papier c'est
la même chose comme les notes de musique
si vous avez vu la création de ça dépend
de chacun entre nous si vous aimez
vraiment quelque chose vous pouvez le
faire facilement et avec toi
alors donc votre grand-mère vous initi
voilà vous avez des petits papiers vous
abusez vous trouvez déjà voilà des
multiples possibilités et puis oui donc
il y a la situation évidemment du combat
il y a l'arrivée de Paul pot aussi dans
les dans les années 70 cela vous allez
quitter le Cambodge pour la France
à l'époque qu'est-ce que vous faites
alors c'est d'abord
vous êtes presque une passion du
dimanche si je peux dire vous travaillez
ailleurs non c'est ça oui au début oui
au début au début je viens du travail
dans un restaurant très connu à Paris
dans le guide bourguignon dans des cœurs
et très connu et j'ai heureusement à ça
souvent que
je monte petit à petit passer là dans la
maison est très connue et il y a
toujours
tous les soirs
François
vers la fin du repas je m'amuse
un petit pliation
c'est pourquoi donc à l'époque je me
souviens que tous les
guides de France sur les restaurants
petit cocotte vers la fin du repas
génial c'est ça
et puis à force d'en faire comme ça pour
votre divertissement
ça devient une passion totale qui vous
est morte
et en ce moment-là
avec moi non c'est grand ça petit à
petit je quittais le restant à Fort prix
etc donc maintenant je vis avec mon âme
et quelquefois ça fait ça fait rire
aussi les gens pourquoi
je plaisantais le bilan je vais les
cocottes en papier mais alors vous avez
raison de dire ça parce que
énormément de monde qui qui est à cet
espace Richou pour voir cette exposition
bien énormément d'enfants c'est ça et et
les cocottes en papier c'est ça c'est
les enfants et et
c'est vrai que ils ont peut-être encore
peut-être plus impressionnés que les
adultes enfin c'est vrai que c'est aussi
avec les yeux il n'y a absolument
éblouis mais grâce à les enfants chaque
homme exposition que je l'ai fait le
plupart des grands personnes qui
critiquent oh c'est dommage pourquoi il
parle
et pourquoi il laissait pas dès qu'il
est comme
et heureusement les petits enfants il
dit oh c'est monotone il fait c'est joli
mais il n'y a pas de couleur qui manque
c'est pourquoi chaque pièce je prends
exprès à ce côté pour faire plaisir aux
enfants l'autre côté
les gants pour retrouver
vous avez quand même une adresse des
doigts exceptionnels mais comme les
musiciens
les ont les droits la même chose la
sensibilité juste avant pour
un son il peut soit appuyer plus fort
plus
près avec ses doigts et moi je fais
vibrer mes papiers
une anecdote personnelle pour vous dire
que parce que moi je suis absolument moi
j'étais justement conservatoire et comme
j'avais beaucoup d'oreilles alors
j'avais très vite pour les dictées et et
un jour j'avais je m'amusais avec des
feuilles et j'ai été renvoyé de la place
parce que le professeur a dit il fait
des cocos en papier pendant la dictée
musicale
c'est la seule fois que mes parents
m'ont défendu en disant non il est
incapable de faire des cocottes en
papier
je me sens au début comme je ne
connaissais pas les pression en français
on m'habille on fait des cocotiers ah je
sais vous travaillez au service des
impôts
et comment
prend de faire une œuvre ça dépend des
œuvres ça dépend des hommes mais il y a
certaines pièces je prends 8 heures ou
même plusieurs jours pour terminer un
seul par exemple comme les insectes que
vous avez vu comment on fait pour sortir
le papier le plus mince possible ça me
permet mais à la fin je peux avoir les
pattes qui correspond presque en vrai
d'accord sinon avec ces gens de papiers
oui les pâtes c'est comme je plie
plusieurs superposer dessus ça devient
une pâte d'éléphant pour
choisir aussi justement dans une œuvre
et ce qui peut y a qu'une feuille de
papier ou il peut y avoir
important
quand vous faites le premier prix ça
permet mais comme sur la deuxième
les uns superposés sur les autres et ça
bloque comme une chaîne d'un maillon
il faut connaître l'endroit où vous
pouvez démonter sinon ça risque de
déchets
c'est du papier c'est le même papier à
chaque fois ou c'est non non ça dépend
ça dépend du grammage le plus souvent
j'ai utilisé du papier soin et les
papiers
et il existe le à partir de 65 g 70 g 80
g 100 g 125 c'est le plus fort
que vous avez vu l'éléphant vous savez
et ça tient très très bien parce que
chaque fois des expositions dans les
musées ils demandent déjà
ignifiger le papier
heureusement que le papier kraft
est-ce que
vous êtes évidemment un génie quoi
parce que il y a toujours besoin il y a
toujours un mètre au-dessus de nous mais
on ne sait pas dans quel endroit
vous avez justement
il y a des artistes que vous connaissez
peut-être au Japon je sais pas qui sont
qui sont aussi des des grands maîtres de
l'origamie mais la technique est
complètement opposée bon mon travail
jusqu'à présent ne plupart des artistes
fait quelques prix quelques fois
géométrique quelques styles architecture
ou
des animaux mais il fait très très plat
ah oui une fois payé il faut que
d'accord
que ce soit
et moi non oui
je m'appelle je ne suis pas écraser les
prix pour risquer de
faire casser tous les films prod du
papier comme vous la renverse retourner
le sujet ça risque de craquer d'accord
et c'est justement le prix je n'ai pas
pressé comme moi c'est difficile à vous
expliquer comme la musique
légèrement afin de former par exemple
pour donner le volume sans laisser les
traces
difficile
ce que je voulais vous demander parce
que vous c'est votre grand-mère qui vous
a initié
est-ce que vous initier aussi des jeunes
générations
c'est pourquoi
j'aime bien de qu'il fait boire d'abord
les sujets ça lui permet de ouverture de
la à partir de la cocotte en papier
c'est devient un homme comme moi j'aime
bien donner les techniques la façon de
prier la façon écraser
mais en réduisant en même temps de la
géométrie mais c'est loin si par exemple
des des jeunes des enfants qui sont qui
a une sorte de passion pour ça est-ce
qui on peut apprendre mais bien sûr on
peut transmettre comme la musique comme
je vous ai dit
ma musique on peut transmettre
facilement mais il faut que tous les
choses il faut aimer d'abord bien sûr si
vous n'aimez pas juste
comme je plonge je nage dedans pour se
sentir que l'eau est frotte ou non
quelquefois même
les pièces que je n'ai jamais fait
est-ce que j'ai capable de le reproduire
alors c'est ça qui est important et vous
avez déjà fait ça quelquefois pendant la
nuit je fais la moitié pendant la nuit
je rêve
il faut remettre ce pli là dans ce sens
pour obtenir ce résultat et quelques
fois je me suis réveillé la nuit pour
mettre quelques prix en France et mon
épouse
ce que j'ai vu et lendemain je
recommencer le travailler et mettre
correctement
si vous êtes arrêtés par la police on
vous demande vos papiers
[Rires]
il faut venir
ça va merci infiniment merci et bravo
parce que on est tous à la fois ému à la
fois on voyage à la fois formidable
merci infiniment partagé un jour avec
vous merci merci
[Musique]